The Wizarding World of Harry Potter is
getting even bigger it's part of a
completely new theme park called epic
Universe set to open sometime in 20125
we have the official name of this
section of the park which will be the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter Ministry
of magic not only are we getting the
ministry of magic we're also getting
Paris set in the 1920s this Paris
section will also be home to one of the
two major attractions in the new
Wizarding World section so we got Paris
Ministry of magic how exactly do these
two connect seems like they definitely
had the lore in mind here as it's being
reported we'll make our way into the
ministry via the flu Network now it's
possible the only way to enter the
ministry will be through a line for what
is the feature attraction of this whole
area we don't have the official name of
the ride yet but there are some pretty
reliable rumors that it will be called
Harry Potter and the battle at the
ministry it's expected to feature ride
Vehicles similar to the elevators that
we see in the films you can expect a
combination of animatronics real sets
and giant wraparound screens guys it
just sounds so incredibly insane